non ce n'est pas pékin c'est ce que la
municipalité de la rochelle souhaite
créer dans le centre ville un parc de
bicyclettes gratuites
inspiré de la mise à disposition du
public de caddies dans les aéroports ou
magasins à grande surface afin d'accéder
rapidement aux zones piétonnières
ce week-end c'était donc le grand
lancement de cette opération dans une
ambiance de kermesse fanfares majorettes
et caravanes de 250 vélos en tête de
laquelle on notait la présence de lucien
neuwirth et de michel crépeau député
maire de la rochelle
pour ce dernier un but primordial
réhabiliter le centre ancien et
commerçants en le débarrassant d'une
effets de la circulation automobile
pollution bruit engorgement et puis le
souhait de voir rochelaise et rochelais
l'itie leurs voitures dans des parkings
de dissuasion pour faire leurs
commissions à bicyclette
le problème est de savoir si les
rochelais tu ne pars utilisent le vélo
comme moyen commandes de transport à
l'intérieur de la vieille ville et
d'autre part s'ils sont capables de le
protéger des prédateurs de le protéger
du vol cette expérience de gratuité qui
est intéressant l'expérience de gratuité
qui font que l'on fait confiance aux
hommes
plutôt que de se méfier d'eux est alors
je crois que ça c'est très important sur
le plan d'un changement de mentalité et
d'état d'esprit
si ça marche c'est à dire si les
citoyens se rendent compte que après
tout ce qui est municipale ça leur
appartient ils le paient ils doivent
s'en occuper si à cette prise de
conscience je dirais collective et bien
c'est une très bonne chose et ça
pourrait être étendu dans d'autres
domaines
pourtant la municipalité a dû transiger
avec les fanatiques de l'automobile
sans doute parce que la population
rochelaise avait refusé en assène
dernière l'installation de parcs m le
conseil municipal n'a pas osé créer d'un
bloc une zone piétonnière une zone
cyclable et une zone réservée aux
automobilistes
et puis lens intel opérations en plein
mois d'août fait qu'il sera difficile de
parler de réussite ou d'échec car il est
bien évident qu'en cette période de
l'année ce sont surtout les enfants qui
empruntent les bicyclettes
c'est une à pertuis qui rendra service à
beaucoup de gens de force ça marche que
je crains c'est que c'est que cheyenne
rôle qui m'enchante parizza et puis bon
refuge il ya la moitié moins
dans notre type de société où tout
s'achète placer des biens communaux sous
la protection du public posera aussi des
problèmes
il faudra sans doute songer à
l'éducation des citoyens qui ont trop
tendance à s'approprier ce qui est mise
à leur disposition
de fait on entendait déjà dans les rues
de la rochelle c'est mon vélo c'est le
mien mais il serait regrettable de
condamner cette tentative même si elle
n'est qu'une demi mesure
les rochelais tout en s'interrogeant sur
le nombre de bicyclettes qui seront
volés sont en tout cas décidé à jouer le
jeu
parfois même avec humour
puis de toute façon c'est très agréable
de faire daby cité par les temps qui
courent tous pensent ne veut pas se
permettre de faire la bicyclette et
d'avoir des pédales qui ne craque pas
tous les rochelais et les rochelaises se
rend compte en dés et se montrant un
syndicat de la bicyclette